good evening I'm Priya nitrogen I happen
to be the
actor of the Franke program in science
and humanities I'm delighted to see you
all here for the Franke distinguished
speaker series in which we have featured
leading thinkers whose work and
intellectual influence transcends
traditional disciplinary boundaries
first I would like to thank our generous
donors
mr. and mrs. Richard Frankie Richard and
Barbara who are here in the audience
thank you so much for not just endowing
haha this series but also being here
with us and participating activity
actively in the of activities that we've
been organizing so second after the talk
I want to mention we have a very nice
reception downstairs in room 108 and I
wanted to remind you that we would
really like to invite you to continue
the conversation there and there's a
really nice food as well as okay and
then haven't required to give you this
notice before I get on to today's
program that the event is actually being
recorded and photographed for
educational archival and promotional
purposes including use in print or the
internet and other forms of media by
attending this event today you agree to
the possibility of your voice or perhaps
your likeness captured by these means
and used only for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby waive any
related right of privacy or publicity
now that I'm done with the recording
formalities this brings us to our
speaker this evening professor Gary
Tomlinson who is a true
transdisciplinary and scholar he serves
as the current director of the Whitney
humanities Center at Yale and Tomlinson
is a musicologist with a long commitment
to multidisciplinary exploration and his
teaching lecturing and scholarship span
and reflect this broad intellectual
diversity central among the the various
strong research interest service have
been the traditions of European
classical music including the history of
opera and early modern musical thought
and practice but his work has always
opened up to broader visions and
perspectives the social context in which
music making happens and he has produced
many wonderful essays and books on music
of the indigenous American societies
jazz cultural and anthropological theory
and the philosophy of history his recent
book is titled culture and the course of
human evolution and I think in this book
he offers a very intriguing and
compelling expanded view of our human
origins story so this latest project is
part of work that he has been doing over
the past couple of years intersecting
with archaeology and evolutionary
biology looking at the role of musical
capacities in the emergence of modern
humanity he has several other books that
which include maybe a list a couple it's
a long list include Monteverde and the
end of the Renaissance music in the
Renaissance magic and and so on
he's also looked at indigenous voice in
the era of European contact and musical
music and historical critique he is also
many of you like I did might have known
of him well I knew of him well before I
met him because of his music
appreciation book text book called
listen which I encountered when I was an
undergraduate at MIT it's now in its
seventh edition so Thomas and Rousseau
was awarded a BA from Dartmouth College
and a PhD from the University of
California at Berkeley he arrived at
Yale in 2010 after several years as the
distinguished Annenberg professor in the
humanities at UPenn he served as a Phi
Beta Kappa visiting scholar and has had
many many prizes from the American
musicological Society the British
Academy is a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and
recipient of Guggenheim and the
MacArthur Fellowship so it goes on and
on so but we'd have much further ado
because I'm very impatient to hear what
he has to say his talk today is titled
the third algorithm the evolution of
human culture Gary it's a real privilege
[Applause]
thanks thank you all for being here
truly thank you all for being here it's
a it's a moist day and and many of you
were eager to go home and find out what
a complete exoneration looks like up
close and personal and and and I want to
thank Priya for the invitation to to
speak under the under the auspices of
the wonderful Frankie program in science
and humanities and of course I too I
never tire of thanking rich and Barbara
for all of their extraordinary support
and over over the years not only for
this program but but for many other
programs at the Whitney and many other
programs at Yale in general
so the third algorithm this is as Priya
has already said I what you modestly put
up covers of a couple of recent books
this is an extension of it said the talk
today is an extension of these of these
recent studies the first of the million
years of music was an attempt to
understand how it is that that that
humans came what the evolutionary
dynamic was by which humans came to be
music and creatures there was a model of
evolutionary cultural evolutionary
dynamic that was mooted there that I
wanted to explore more and that's what
happened in culture and the course of
human evolution and it is never there's
no bottom to this question it I go on
exploring it and and and some further
exploration is what I will be talking
about today the algorithm referred to in
my title I will get to the third I have
to get to the first and second first
however the algorithm in my title what I
mean by an algorithm in this case is is
indeed a set of conditions I don't quite
mean you know the Google and Amazon
things that are controlling on our lives
but rather I said a set of conditions
that that that set processes in motion
basically and and the first and foremost
algorithm in evolutionary thinking as
you all know is Darwin's natural
selection
here's the algorithm if you have a group
of organisms a population of organisms
that passes along traits to successive
generations that is to say there is
inheritance and you have a in that that
inheritance there is some variation of
those traits from generation to
generation and all of this is happening
in a landscape of not unlimited
resources
there will be selection the process is
set in motion by those conditions alone
I'm not going to read quotes from
quotations from a lot of my slides today
but I do want to read these wonderful
words from the beginning of chapter 4
and on the Origin of Species can it be
thought improbable that variation is
useful in some way to each being in the
great and complex battle of life should
sometimes occur in the course of
thousands of generations
if such do occur can we doubt
remembering that many more individuals
are born than can possibly survive that
individuals having any advantage however
slight over others would have the best
chance of surviving and procreating
their kind on the other hand we may feel
sure that any variation in the least
degree injurious would be rigidly
destroyed this preservation of favorable
variations than the rejection of
injurious variations I call natural
selection now Darwin in his in his model
of natural selection builds the question
of resources into it you can see that in
this quotation in the in the reference
to the many more individuals that are
born than can possibly survive or the
complex battle of life and indeed his
his model for for thinking about for
thinking about population dynamics in
the first place was malthus's model
Thomas Malthus from around 1800 the
Malthusian model is as most of you most
of you are familiar with is absolutely
bound up with the waxing and waning of
resources but this when we take when we
take seriously this question of
resources we need to move beyond natural
selection to a second algorithm a second
algorithm that that has always been
present you can we can see it implicitly
in in Darwin's model has always been
present in evolutionary thinking since
Darwin but has in recent decades
burgeoned into primary importance in in
evolutionary thinking and this second
algorithm is the algorithm of niche
construction niche construction this now
is is a feedback loop a feedback cycle
between the environment and the
organisms the top of the feedback cycle
here is essentially natural sense
Darwin's natural selection the
environment exerts as the metaphor
usually has it exerts a selective
pressure on organisms living in it some
variants of those or some variants are
arts are selected for other variants are
selected against because of the nature
of the affordances and constraints that
the environment
offers the other side of this feedback
loop however is what niche construction
wants to focus on and that is the fact
that organisms change their environments
in living in them that there are no
organisms anywhere in the history of
life here or anywhere else wherever life
may be that could possibly be so
light-footed that they would have no
impact whatsoever on their environments
if they do have impacts on their
environments however we need to take
account of that you know a model of
natural selection because the selective
gradient the selective terrain of the
environment is not only changing the
genomes of these of these organisms
through many many generations but the
organisms in their behaviors in their
life ways are changing the environment
so the environment is changing the
organisms and vice versa now if we were
to leap ahead to talk about cultural
organisms cultural animals that is
animals that that have cultural
behaviors we would immediately
understand that that in order to think
about niche construction of cultural
animals we're going to have to think
about the role of culture in changing
the environment right culture is and the
cultures of animals are not simply
neutral they are part of their niche
construction so the question of how
these cultures change their their niches
change the nature of the construction is
one that we will have to build into our
our our feedback cycle of niche
construction now I've gotten ahead of
myself because I haven't yet said what I
think where culture might be here's a
definition of culture from that
evolutionists have taken up for about
for about the last thirty years or so in
trying to understand the dynamics of the
dynamics of culture as it plays a part
in evolutionary process there it is Pete
Richardson and and Robert Boyd
information learned and transmitted from
one generation to another through
teaching imitation and similar means the
crucial elements of this are the
learning of information the transmitting
of information through some sort of
imitative or pedagogical means now this
is a hugely broad view of culture its
above you of culture that is is that is
certainly broad enough to to open out
our notion of cultural animals well
beyond Homo sapiens in the world today
we can think of songbird cultures we can
think of humpback whale cultures we
think of spermwhale cultures by the way
then the this is only recently really
made clear but the the the the click
codes by which that are learned and
transmitted from generation to
generation are come rather complex codes
by which Wales not only identify their
pods but they also identify individuals
within their pods wale cultures in other
words we can think of of course a number
of a number of non-human primates in the
world today that have cultures according
to this broad definition chimpanzees
bonobos maybe gorillas some other
monkeys even beyond beyond the great
apes so this a broad view of culture is
the first point the second point before
I move on from this is that is that we
need to think a little bit more broadly
about about the information that is at
stake here
we can think first there is a particular
kind of information that I want to get
to that is that is and that is the
information that is embodied in culture
the information that is learned and
transmitted in culture the it takes it
plays a role in it is an outgrowth of a
much much broader kind of a kind of
information a much more broader
foundation informational foundation this
broad informational foundation is we can
think of as as as operative
correspondences that are evolved into
living things think of think of the
relationship between the correspondences
between a messenger RNA molecule and a
DNA molecule or the correspondences
between a messenger RNA molecule with
its codons and the amino acids that bond
to those codons making up polypeptides
proteins finally these are these are all
informational processes in any useful
definition of information that has come
along since the 1940s these would be
considered informational processes but
the information and culture is of a
different sort the information and
culture is is information about it is
information about the niche it is
information about the sociality of
animals in on the niche it is about the
it is the information about about how it
is that they move forward in in in in
constructing their niche the question
then comes to be how did this difference
in kinds of information come along
how did aboutness arise
and that takes us to the third algorithm
the third algorithm is sign-making or
semiosis semiosis is a special animal
interaction with the world
and it creates a very distinctive kind
of information processing in in in its
in its complexity and I've laid out a
little a little chart here that gives
you that gives gives you a starting
point as I see it for semiosis again
this is a view of semiosis not as doubt
that is going to be like culture is
going to be broadly dispersed across
many many animals many more animals in
fact our semiotic then finally our
cultural animals in in this view where
do we start we start with the notion of
an attentive animal the notion of an
animal that can pay attention to things
this is not true of all animals it's
certainly not true of plants microbes
and other and-and-and-and molecules
themselves but the notion of attention
is has been much research recently by
people from many many different fields
they take in the notion of top-down
processing from from complex central
nervous functions such as memory
learning even rudimentary memory and
rudimentary learning they taking into
account also the filtering of the the
sent the sensory stimuli that come that
come to the to the animal from the
outside world they take all of those
things into account but what all of
these views of semiosis all of these use
of attention agree on whatever there are
the differences is that is that
attention is first of all a capacity to
winnow or to or to focus or to to to
well to focus on certain stimuli from
among all of those stimuli that are
impinging on the animal at any at any
given moment this notion of a winnowing
or a focusing is something that then
enables animals to bring into salience
certain stimuli while not attending is
quite so much to other stimuli right and
not only that because it brings them
into salience in conjunction with these
top-down neural systems it enables it
enables the easier memorization of them
it enables learning about the stimuli it
enables many things but one thing is
there's one thing that the these
attention researchers don't quite pick
out pick out as often as I think then
and that is the recursive quality to
attention if you have an animal that is
able to winnow from among all the
stimuli impinging on it just a set of
stimuli and pay attention to those well
we can recursively see that that animal
given whatever the limit within the
limits of its sensorium and and its
cognitive patterns that animal might be
able to winnow further and pay attention
to a fewer us a smaller number of
stimuli within the great group of
stimuli that it might otherwise have
paid attention to this opens up
something that is it to me immensely
important it opens up the possibility of
of attending not only to things as in
their holes but attending to aspects or
qualities or traits of things in in in
very particular ways and this opens up
the possibility then of a part for whole
Association whereby whereby an animal
could could focus could attend to one
aspect of something and that aspect of
the something of whatever it was could
refer to the whole something even though
it was a single aspect of it what I'm
describing here is of course a
rudimentary sign it is semiosis in
action what comes about at this moment
is that the quality or the aspect of the
broader the broader set of stimuli that
is being focused on can come to refer to
that broader set it can come to to to
mean that broader set it can come to be
about that broader set here's an
instance here's our European Robin back
again this is a very intelligent animal
able to able to attend in all kinds of
complex ways to the world around it it
has been fed during its childhood by say
regurgitated food by from its parents
but it has also attended to the fact
that his parents eat red berries it has
attended to this it by but by this
recursive principle that I've been
talking about it can also it can also
attend to qualities of those berries
individual qualities it doesn't have to
take on every aspect of the berries to
know that those berries might be
something it might eat it can it can
take it doesn't have to take on the
relationship of the berries to the
leaves or the branches on which they
grow it doesn't have to take it doesn't
have to take on many things but it might
take on just a single quality of them
say the redness of the berries right
once it do it once it does that once it
makes a part for a whole association
between the redness and the berries as a
whole it is
a simple sign of the berry a sign of
what it eats redness then can connote
can mean can refer to what it eats a
sign and its object now this is a very
simple kind of sign it is in fact what
charles sanders purse famously called an
icon it is the simplest kind of sign but
it is one it is a simple sign a
foundation from which a hierarchy of
more and more complex signs will be
built so here's another instance of an
icon an icon then for purse for me as
well for for terence deacon who is
referred to in the slide who who is an
EO person of the first order who has
done all kinds of analysis of person
semiosis an icon is a sign that there's
a qualitative resemblance to its object
in this case we have a painting of a
woolly mammoth on a cave wall it's pêche
merrill in southern france this refers
to the woolly mammoth itself to the real
thing it refers to the real thing by
virtue of only certain certain aspects
of that real thing the outline of its
body of its body shape is what it is
what it uses it doesn't it doesn't
require the the colour of the of the of
the of the wool on the mammoth to be to
be a part of the sign it doesn't require
the color of the tusks it doesn't
require any other facts about the
mammoth to be involved in order to
become an icon of the mammoth because it
picks out one qualitative resemblance
and and associates that with the whole
thing the next more complex kind of sign
and the it rises in complexity in part
because animals come along whose central
nervous systems enable them to construct
this greater Crump laxity especially in
their capacities for learning and memory
is as what what purse called the index
and this is a sign that strikes up a
pointing and indicating relation with
its object a causal relation or just a
relationship of proximity in some cases
the most famous index of all is smoke as
an index of fire how does an index come
about in the in in in the in the in the
cognizance of an animal well it has to
depend first of all on some earlier
learning that that smoke and fire were
associated so it is going to depend all
already on some kind of learning
capacity fairly complicated learning
capacity some kind of
well developed memory not just a
transient working memory but some kind
of episodic memory that can remember
episodes from early in the animal's life
but once an animal has this it can then
strike up a relationship between a
present experience where there's smoke
only no fire that has been perceived yet
and fire and an earlier experience where
that was a complete experience of smoke
experienced with fire it can put these
two things together but notice that in
putting these two things together it has
constructed a not only an indexical sign
but it has also depended on iconicity it
is dependent on the way icons work
because the present-day incomplete
experience is made complete by making it
an icon of an earlier remembered
experience right there's a qualitative
likeness of these two things and index
smoke as referring to meaning fire the
most complex kind of symbol most complex
kind of sign for purse was the symbol
this is a kind of sign that that in the
world today - all our evidence there are
no animals that make symbols except for
Homo sapiens in in an earlier world
there may have been some other hominids
that made symbols Neanderthal Homo
neanderthalensis the Neanderthals are
the best candidate for that there was a
very vexed question as to whether they
were symbolic creatures or not a symbol
is a sign that that that relies on a
systematic relationship in a group of
symbols in order that is somehow
governed by rules by conventions in
order to to come to its its signifying
function it doesn't signify except once
it becomes a part of some sort of
organized system of signs now the most
pervasive and most foundational and most
important kind of symbolism that modern
humans all practice is language and it
is a hugely developed kind of and an
interesting kind of symbolism but the
words in a language the words in a
language point to one another they point
to one another in all kinds of ways
adverbs point to verbs verbs point to
nouns pronouns point to nouns or they
might point to whole groups of other
words they can point in all kinds of
interesting ways all kinds of words are
busy pointing to other words this by the
way this pointing reminds us of the
index and we're going to find that the
just as the index was based on the icon
for its structure the symbol is based on
the index for its structure so first of
all we have indexical relationships
pointing relationships among all the
signs all the signs in a system of signs
that that will become symbols but by
virtue of this pointing relationship
there's indexical relationships the
whole system then comes to be able to
point beyond itself for example to the
world as language can point to the world
so we've got two kinds two orders of
indexicality here the indexicality that
governs the the relationships within the
system
the indexicality that then enables that
governed system that rule bound system
to point beyond itself to the world at
large here we reach reach the apex of
the complexity of signs and and perhaps
we will step back and and and and just
have a quick review we start from a
foundation of information think of the
those messenger RNA molecules and DNA
molecules semiosis grows out of a
broader a broader realm of information
when in fact central nervous systems
come along that are complex enough to
start doing performing some of the
functions that i was just describing
sorry wrong direction culture then is a
semiotic is a semiotic enterprise
through and through it is it is it is
about signs and they're about us it uses
it it takes as its stuff signs and
they're about us and finally in the most
complex kinds of signs the symbol for
example we see another possibility
within culture that is to say complex
cultural systems systemic culture of one
sort or another and we see also then
then to just review again information is
about is about cooperative
correspondence evolved operative
correspondence semiosis is about
aboutness and that's where meaning comes
comes into this culture is about
learning and transmission and then we
finally get to the most complex kind of
cultures systemic cultures so let's now
turn to am I still going backwards I
don't know they're on there I'm going
forward
let's now turn to turn to some
Paleolithic cultural systems and think
about how they are semiotic and how they
work here's an ax shoe lien hand ax and
a shoe lien by face
this one from about 700,000 years ago it
is a thing of beauty to those of us who
by the way those of us who were tried to
make one boy is it boy is it hard and
this is 700,000 years ago I don't even
come close to Neanderthals but in any
case this technology in order to make
such a such a by face by the way this
technology was was was already emerged
about 1 and 3/4 million years ago Homo
sapiens emerged between 300 and 200,000
years ago this is a hugely ancient
technology practiced by many different
hominid species right it goes way way
back in order to make one of these you
take you take a cobble you take a core
and you take a hammer stone and you
start chipping away at the cobble what
when you chip away at the cobble cobble
as anybody who has tried this
immediately learns when you cheat you
cannot take a cobble and say I know how
and a surely in hand X is going to come
out of this all you can do is chip away
at the cobble and a flake is chipped off
and that flaking of the chip then forms
an index pointing you to the next
gesture and that forms an index pointing
you to the next gesture and an index
pointing you to the next gesture at
every moment you are concatenating signs
indexes from one gesture to the next
that helped you finally if you you're
pretty good at it get to something as
beautifully symmetrical as as this hand
ax is this is then a comp a pretty
complex array of indexes that enables
this cultural system to be passed along
and and to be taught and and transmitted
from generation to generation
but notice that it's just a kind of a
willy-nilly sequence of indexes of
indexes it is not it is not a sequence
of indexes that is somehow prearranged
that is somehow hierarchical that is
organized in more than a very very
rudimentary manner if we look at a later
stone technology level wall point making
this now is the stone technology that
came came into existence the debates
raged somewhere between 300 and 400
thousand years ago maybe somewhere on
that time scale at any rate it is has
been studied to a fairly well within
Association association with
Neanderthals it's also been studied a
lot recently in association with our
forebears in Africa Neanderthals of
course in Europe and here's how it works
you take the Cobble now and the end from
1 to 2 what you're doing is you're
taking a cobble
you're chipping off flicking flakes in a
rather systematic way around the edge of
the cobble right once you do that you're
in you're prepared now but because
you've formed sharp edges there you you
are prepared to begin to form a convex
surface on the top of the cobble by in
number three chipping off flaking off
bits on the top of the cobble now and in
number four that process is completed
and and if you do this right in number
five you may need one or more other
strokes at kinds of kinds of Hammer
hammer strokes you may need to lop off
one end of it depending upon the shape
of the cobble and so on but if you've
done this right one strike here
represented by the arrow and number five
will break off a foot a finished point
or at least a point that only needs a
slight retouching right now think about
this as a system a system of indexes
first of all it is systematic in a way
that the Eshoo lien bi-face indexes were
not at all systematic this is not a
willy-nilly array of indexes one
following after another in an
unpredictable fashion it is a set of
higher archives different kinds of
indexes in in regard to the the core
that you started with that have to be
arranged in just this way or you will
not get to the final product the point
will not will not come off it as those
of us who have tried to do this level of
eye technology learning technology
learned very quickly it is very very
hard to get this right but it is it is
it is a it's a it's it's quite a
sophisticated technology the fact that
all of these indexes are arranged in
this in this in this this hierarch IIST
a set of different kinds of indexes that
have to be ordered just so in order to
get the final product is why I think of
this not just as an indexical system but
as a hyper indexical system something
has happened here in the ordering of
indexes that is decisively different
from what happened in the alien hand ax
okay what we have now by this time is is
hominins several species of hominids we
keep discovering more and more probably
but but in just one last week with homo
loosen insists that you may have noticed
in in the papers but at this point in
the evolution of hominids we've got a
lot of a lot of complex complex
semiosis that is going on that is being
transmitted from generator
degeneration in in the culture we've got
cultural systems of some complexity what
is the impact of these cultural systems
then on the niche construction on our
second algorithm on that that cultural
niche construction we were talking about
before well here's a diagram that adds
now something down at the bottom that
tries to tries to show this what happens
with these cultural systems is that even
though they are generated by the overall
cycle the feedback cycle of niche
construction in cultural animals even
though they are generated from that
cycle they come to have a holistic
quality first of all because they have
to be passed on think of the level while
technology it must be passed on as a
whole or it doesn't work because of this
holistic transmission there their
integrated nature as a system comes to
be more marked in the cultures that
practice them they have an autonomy from
the other aspects of the cultural
practices of the cult of the of the
culture they have a robustness of
systematic integration perhaps as well
all of these things form what I call
cultural epicycles they form cultural
forces technologies in this case
cultural forces that that that kind of
come to stand outside of the overall
feedback loop of niche construction
because they are so autonomous in their
in their integrated holism
they come to stand outside of that
feedback loop and they come then to be
able to feed forward into the loop and
bias it and redirect it and change its
direction finally right a simple example
of this would be the control of fire one
need only think for a minute to think
that's a technology it's a it's a pretty
complex technology probably mastered
between 700,000 and a hundred thousand
and a million years ago by hominins
though the dating is again another vexed
problem but nonetheless think of the
control of fire and think of what that
would do once it was once there was a
systematic control of fire think what it
would do for the the in terms of
redirecting the niche construction right
all right
cultural epicycles redirecting nichkhun
need redirecting cultural niche
construction let's look at such an
epicycle the bead making epicycle bead
making is hugely dispersed in in hominin
cultures probably only in Homo sapiens
culture but maybe also in the answer to
all cultures in any case in sapien
culture
our own ancestors cultures and related
sapien groups it goes back at least a
hundred thousand years probably more
like a hundred and thirty thousand years
what archaeologists mean by bead making
is to take any small object a seashell
an ostrich fragment of an ostrich egg
shell in another instance a tooth of an
animal that has been hunted a piece of
mineral a piece of amber take any small
object and drill it through or pierce it
so as to be hung so as to be hung on a
strap an anklet a bracelet a necklace so
as to be hung on hair so as to be hung
on clothing bead making why that the
mystery about bead making is why does it
pop up everywhere Homo sapiens goes all
right it in in vastly different
geographical arenas vastly different
niches bead making pops up what is what
is making this epicycle what is the
force that makes this epital Abdul cycle
take shape for me it has to do precisely
with the complexity of semiotic
cognition what you've got now is is is
is early humans who are who are working
in with indexes in pretty complicated
ways we see that already in in the in
the levallois point making but you've
all said that has to that's that
complicated semiosis must also be
reflected in the complications the the
growing complications of the social
structures of these groups themselves
what is probably coming on board are our
new registers of kinship relations new
registers of social status and social
power right but as these things come on
board as the complexity of the society
grows what is also manifesting itself
are are invisible realms of culture so
to speak these are not realms that are
necessarily smacking you in the face you
cannot tell that somebody is is akin in
in especially a distant kin simply by
looking at them simply by encountering
them this is now something that needs
that has become invisible in the
practice of culture itself and needs
then to be made visible what could be
more more easily understood than that
these cultures would all of them one
after another use their sophisticated
technologies so as to construct markers
by which social difference could be
registered now these were no doubt these
beads were no jet no doubt not the only
social markers they scarification of the
body painting tattooing there may have
been many a clothing the kinds of
clothing that was worn
it's just that meat making is the one
that was made with materials that have
that have that have endured down down to
our time and can be studied by
archaeologists but it shows us it seems
to me the way in which a cultural
epicycle can become necessary in the
growing complexity of the cultural niche
construction of a group of humans it
shows us something else too
it shows us because because if we take a
group say this is a group that has been
studied or at least an instance that has
been studied if we take humans a hundred
thousand years ago in blombo's cave and
so on the southern edge of south africa
they've been they've been harvesting
shellfish for their food for a long long
time now for tens of thousands of years
maybe they've been harvesting shellfish
when they come to be a beat making
culture using the seashells as their
beads suddenly a new affordance from the
from the the the a new new resource in
the niche has has been invented so to
speak by their cultural practice right
seashells are no longer trash to be
thrown on the mitten seashells now had
the capacity to become signs of social
complexity so what happens in this in
this episode click this epicyclic niche
construction is not only not only the
the redirecting of the the cycle of
niche construction okay in all kinds of
possible directions but in the course of
that redirecting the uncovering of new
resources perhaps the meeting up against
of new constraints in the environment
all kinds of things can happen in terms
of the affordances and constraints of
the environment here's another kind of
epicyte this is a whole class of
epicycle of cultural epicycles as far as
i'm
and that is ritual so what is a ritual
well first of all it is behavior that
has been systematized its repeatable
behavior its distinct by a systematic
systematic organization from everyday
activities that don't somehow count as
ritual and all of these features it
begins to look like the holistic systems
of cultural epicycles and like epicycles
it might reshape the affordances and
constraints even by using the the the
materials the materials as a part of its
distinct cultural system it might
it might reshape the affordances and
constraints of the environment in the
way that I was just that I was just
saying if the autonomy and robustness of
the system might be very very much
marked by by the systematized repeatable
nature of it but there's one new
ingredient that we haven't introduced
yet that is absolutely basic to ritual
and that is that there's a double system
at NASA time at a systematization that
stake here on the one hand there are the
elements of the ritual that are
systemized and systematized in
relationship to one another but on the
other hand the relationship between the
ritual and the broader comfor is
systematized as well you do not have a
funerary ritual unless somebody has died
you don't have a puberty ritual unless
somebody is passing through puberty so
that double systematization is is it
seems to be crucial in a definition of
ritual and and in trying to understand
the origins of ritual and it suggests
that those origins are very very ancient
origins in fact it suggests to me that
what we need in a culture for it to
practice ritual is hyper indexicality it
is not net yet symbolism you don't have
to have language in order to practice
ritual and I think we can see but what
you do have to have is a performed
system of indexes we've seen perform
systems of indexes after all and
levallois technology what you have to
have also is the the indexical relation
of that system to the broader culture
the hyper indexical doubleness I was
talking about all of this brings you to
the verge of symbolism but it doesn't
necessarily require symbolism
you don't need language for ritual this
is an idea that is is rather foreign to
too many anthropologist when they think
about ritual but it seems to me that
that we can look back deep in our deep
history and see and see creatures who
were not entirely like us in many many
ways and yet had already had begun to
form rudimentary ritual structures in
their societies and one of the ways they
were not like us was they did not they
did not yet have modern language they
had proto languages of indexical sorts
complex no doubt in their communicative
capacities but nothing like the full
grammar syntax and lexicon of that makes
language the symbolic medium par
excellence that it is here's an instance
of that rather lurid picture of uh-uh
this is a representation of
but a site Boxgrove in the southern in
southern england that has been has been
excavated and excavated and excavated it
was a stunning site when it was found
there what was found on this site was
was evidence of hominin hunting
apparently and also butchering then of a
rhinoceros of several horses a whole a
whole system a cultural system there was
a waterhole that you can see that in the
picture I love this kind of picture by
the way this this kind of peaceable
kingdom right with a twist all these
animals kind of wandering around kind of
you know happily sort of what looking at
them but nonetheless whatever is not not
necessarily what what Boxgrove would
have looked like five hundred thousand
years ago some of these things are what
would have this would have looked like
at the moment of butchering this
rhinoceros number one we know that this
person making stone tools stone tools
were made on the site in order to
butcher the rhinoceros we know where the
stones came from they came from the
limestone cliffs at the back we even
have we even have places where cobbles
were picked off the limestone cliffs and
tested right there and deemed not worthy
of being carried over to the to the
rhinoceros that too has been analyzed by
these archaeologists this site has just
been has just revealed a treasure trove
of information we can imagine then the
complexity of and the fraud complexity
of this scene which is pictured here as
well you've got you've got some of the
humans that need to be that need to be
warding off the hyenas and the other
scavengers that are going to be
surrounding them you've got others that
are making the stone tools some of the
food would be consumed immediately on
the scene some of the suit food would be
lugged away probably to be cooked a lot
of complexity to this right it is not
necessarily a ritual scene and yet we
are in a hyper indexical situation that
could even easily give rise to ritual
and we are five hundred thousand years
ago two hundred thousand years and more
before homo sapiens emerged a hundred
and fifty thousand years or so before
Neanderthals emerged this would have
been Homo heidelbergensis in all
likelihood usually taken to be the
common ancestor of both Homo sapiens and
Neanderthals okay
another review again we look at the
pyramid the the fundamental information
with his correspondence at the bottom
the semiosis with it's about 'no sand
meaning the culture with its learning
and teaching
transmission complex cultural systems
epicyclic niche construction or is
involved there but notice where I've
arrayed that the kinds of signs that we
talked about at first culture can
subsist perfectly well with icons and
indexes
I don't think cultural animals can
subsist with icons alone but with icons
and indexes culture can emerge for
complex systemic culture you need at
least the hyper index as I'm calling it
or perhaps full-fledged symbolism of
course my view is you do not need
full-fledged symbolism for this cultural
complex idiom to emerge hyper
indexicality is enough and indeed my
view is that hyper indexicality lasted a
long long time in Homo sapiens history
and it was only after the hundred
thousand year mark that's something that
that modern language fully coalesced it
coalesced around we sent coalescing in
other words and now again to think again
once more about the the way in which
epicycles bias niche construction here's
one more chart you've got a complex
ordered cultural archive think of the
level wha technology that I've shown you
up in the in the right hand corner this
brings about hierarchy systems holistic
transmission robustness autonomy all
these things I've talked about already
cultural epicycles with their feed
forward bias that changes the course of
niche construction new affordances and
constraints that then can then be that
can then be identified and Exploited in
in niche construction feeding back into
a niche that is now going to be
constructed in a new and different way
right all of this process it seems to me
it's a process that in in our deep
history began easily by a hundred
thousand years ago probably longer than
that probably a good deal longer than
that began to open further domains so to
speak of cultural activity for hominins
not only Homo sapiens but but a wide
group of different kinds of hominids
probably probably and I want to finish
by talking then about some of those new
domains some of these reach back beyond
farther beyond Homo sapiens some of them
are our sapient in particular but all of
them show the encroaching of this this
powerful epicycle epicyclic niche
construction that that can that can
simply expand out the expansion
abilities of the building of the new
so here's the first of them
hyperdeveloped technology well this
might seem obvious right we've talked a
lot about technology today the notion of
hyperdeveloped technology as a new
domain of niche construction is one that
comes on board pretty early here's an
example these are there these are a
couple of the showing and Spears wooden
javelins that were unearthed in the
1990s in Germany well over three hundred
thousand years old by the most recent
and authoritative authoritative dating
far this is long long before Homo
sapiens made it in in any persistent way
in Europe it is it is right at the
beginning of the of the Neanderthal
history in Europe these are very very
ancient they don't they may not look to
you like hyper developed technology
however these javelins first of all they
are aerodynamically wonderful number one
number two they were carved out of the
hardest wood at the bottom of a spruce
trunk this is all being done with stone
tools right this is extraordinary an
extraordinarily hyper developed
technology to counter yet something like
this the fact that these wooden Spears
were of course wood is is not very not
very durable in terms of archaeological
spans of like three hundred thousand
years the fact that they were preserved
is is a small miracle in and of itself
another hyper developed technology the
bow and arrow bow and arrow is now a
very very complicated composite
technology the arrow itself needs needs
feathers at the end it needs it needs a
point at that is that is hafted onto
onto the the shaft at the forward end
the bow is another complex composite
tool the recent the recent notions of
bow and arrow technology that that
archaeologists have been putting forward
suggested in africa this may go back by
some estimates five hundred thousand
years that's a pretty pretty large
estimate most people sort of settle well
over a hundred thousand years ago some
somewhere between 100 and 500 thousand
years ago we don't have specimens of
bows and arrows all we have are points
that seem to have been used to make
arrows in some cases right the stone
points are the only parts of these that
have survived but but the technology for
making these points goes back something
like three hundred thousand years or
more here's the astonishing garen moon
rock shelter and Arnhem Land in the
the Northern Territory of Australia
probably between 28 and 48 thousand
years ago I'm not showing it to you for
these amazing amazing paintings all over
all over the ceiling of this naturally
naturally eroded away kind of Cathedral
effect here I'm showing it to you
because we need to pay attention to
Australia when we talk about
hyperdeveloped technologies the latest
evidence which just was published last
year his pretty conclusively pretty
conclusively settled the date by which
Homo sapiens made it to Australia 60 to
65 thousand years ago this is hugely
ancient first of all and second of all
it they have made it to Australia at a
time when while there was never a time
when Australia was connected to the
Indonesian islands by a by a land bridge
right at the at the periods of greatest
glaciation when the sea levels were
lowest they were still something like 70
kilometers of open sea to get across
these people were seafarers in some
fashion and it's utterly astonishing
that they could be we have no we have no
record because none we'd have no
president no preserved boats or anything
that looks like boat technology from
anywhere in the Paleolithic era it would
be wonderful to find it they were using
it and it might be that home owners own
ancestors got announced just last week
was also a seafaring creature from an
entirely different lineage than homo
sapiens that - there was no land bridge
to lose only a Philippine island where
where those fossils were discovered ever
either
alright further new domains the release
from proximity this is a great phrase
that was introduced by an archaeologist
and a number of years ago what it means
is the establishment of the off-line
imagine an imaginary or the offline
imagination in some way think of think
of the the capacity of baboons to
interact in complex ways socially with
one another it's a very complex
sociality but it's all face to face they
interact
according to face-to-face transactions
the notion of the the question of when
it is that huh in our hominin evolution
when it is that hominins move beyond
that notion onto into into an imaginary
that that could could posit interactions
that might come tomorrow could remember
interactions that came yesterday and
work on the basis of those could could
begin to extend the imagination far
beyond the senses that's what the this
release from proximity is about we see
it
in cave paintings the very notion of
painting this fabulous panel from
Groucho they the very notion of painting
painting animals on on a wall with these
iconic since iconic patterns of the sort
that we talked about with the woolly
mammoth at the beginning when the
animals are not there the animals are
outside is a really a release from
proximity of an extraordinary sort in
itself but much earlier in the garage
survey we see something like this in
size piece of ochre from blum blum bose
cave in South Africa more than seventy
thousand years ago was when it was
incised in size for what purpose we
don't know but in size with some sort of
intent clearly and this was not a
haphazard incision that was that was
done this too has been studied very
microscopically in fact that there are a
number of pieces like this
they've been Scottish studied
microscopically to understand how they
came about it didn't come about from
somebody chopping meat on top of on top
of a piece of ochre it came about
because for some reason this ochre had
in size in this way could have some
meaning beyond its presence as a piece
of ochre I've already talked about beads
here that here is some of the shell
beads from blombo's cave also more than
seventy thousand years ago this too is
the notion of those invisible aspects of
sociality is another case in point of
the release from proximity one of the
most famous instances of this over forty
thousand years old from southwestern
Germany the so called woven mensch the
lion mane of holding Stein städel this
is an extraordinary car carved ivory
mammoth ivory about about about this
tall of a creature that could never have
been seen for which one had to have a
drought and dramatic release from
proximity in order to come up with the
notion in the first place
half half human or humanoid bipedal
upright but with a lion head at the top
of it or a feline head at the top of it
so the release from proximity the
release from proximity is working
hand-in-hand with what I've already
talked about the doubled indexicality of
ritual this complex doubled indexicality
is bringing you as I said before close
to the notion of a full fledged
symbolism and here for my illustration
well I can't resist giving this crazy
painting from 1883 victor kuznetsov
russian landscape painter and say
painted russian scenes and every once in
a while he indulged him
a fan herself and painted a stone-age
scene it's the next door it's an
extraordinary thing almost like that
peaceable kingdom we saw there we saw a
few slides that go the doubled
indexicality of ritual hyper hyper
indexicality what do I mean by hyper
hyper indexicality well you heard at the
beginning that I'm a musicologist by
trade and some music had to enter in
here at some point these are these are
this is a single pipe viewed from
several different several different
advantages again from constructed from a
Griffon vulture radius of wing bone of a
Griffon vulture say ulna it's an all
that goodness thank you thank you Rick
any any bird information he's the man he
is the man thank you Rick he's a Mona in
any case this fantastic pipe over 40,000
years old the reason that I call music
hyper hyper indexicality is because
though music in the modern world all
human music is absolutely imbricated and
tied in with and overlaid on and your
interweaved with symbolism it cannot it
cannot not be because we are absolutely
inveterate habitual symbol a symbolic
creatures today in the world so music is
always involved with symbolic acts in in
in modern humanity but the music itself
in the nature of its construction
musical systems across the world in the
nature of their construction and in the
nature of the the cognitive reception of
them and processing of them can be
thought of not in fact as symbolic at
all but as the most hyper developed kind
of ordered indexes that humans have
invented hence the hyper hyper
indexicality music is is indexical on
many different levels at once even city
even thing what music that we would
think of as simple music is is this
indexical on many different levels at
once
temporal different temporal levels
different scales at which at which at
which things are pointing to one another
in indicating one another indicating
things that might or might not come with
the next gesture in the music hyper
hyper indexicality
full-fledge symbolism of course the the
the best example of this is language
here's a map of language families across
the world and finally emerging cultural
difference / extended niche construction
why have I linked these two things
together well perhaps it is clear from
what I've said already but the human
capacity to construct cultural
difference had to have emerged in
relation to systematic epicyclic niche
construction the systematized epicyclic
epicycles of the niche construction is
is is pointing up new resources new
possibilities it is then tapping into
the the behavioral flexibility of these
cultural creatures who then devise
according to these new resources new
strategies for niche construction but by
the same token as they construct new
niches these novel niches are
solidifying the differing cultural
practices by which they by which they
were constructed in the first place
right so you've got from from somewhere
between a hundred and seventy thousand
years ago you've got lineage the lineage
of humans that populated the whole world
that is moving back through africa
interbreeding with other hominid other
sapient groups that are they're already
moving out from africa and moving across
the whole world so quickly that that by
sixty five thousand years ago they're
already in Australia you've got all of
this happening on the basis of the
successive construction of niche after
niche after niche that can only come
about through the the offline imaginary
the the complexities of epicyclic niche
construction that enables the discovery
of new resources at every moment that
then reshapes the whole the whole nature
of the niche construction in that
circumstance but that also then from
forms a solidification of certain kinds
of a practice a set of unfolding
cultural differences across the world
given the niches that are constructed
right and this one of my favorite maps
it's out of date now in many ways but it
shows my toka it shows a very simplified
picture of mitochondrial lineages traced
it is the l1 lineage in Africa l1 and l2
moved back into Africa l1 see l3
moved out of Africa the M the M path was
the path that went along sent the south
southern coast of Asia the end path went
into Central Asia and turned back into
Europe with an R path that is not even
I'm not even named here and so on and so
forth
all the way to successive waves that
made it all the way to the tip of South
America finally between say 70,000 years
ago and well the tip of South America
probably something on the order of
15,000 years ago but the message here is
that the populating of the world could
only come about by virtue of the
diversified cultural niche construction
that was made available by systematized
semiosis that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you we do have a microphone that
that ty has I'll ask you to use it if
you want to ask a question can you pass
that down
well that was wonderful
thank you very much sure everyone agrees
um so you take us back 500,000 years and
kind of up to the verge of modern
civilization and you have extremely slow
development during most of that time
compared to what we're used to right
right and then in the second half of the
last century
you'd begin to see this incredible yeah
yeah incredible high school organization
cultural development getting faster and
faster year by year yeah and I wonder if
you could comment on that trajectory
absolutely absolutely yeah it's a great
it's a great question and and it is and
it is a very real trajectory I would say
only one thing about the trajectory as
you've laid it out
I think the newest archeological
evidence suggests that the acceleration
is happening almost as much as a hundred
thousand years ago it is really taking
off it is not suggesting that something
unique happened 45,000 years ago in
Europe with the Upper Paleolithic
revolution that's deeply out because so
much African evidence is coming on board
now that just in the last 25 years it is
just remaking the whole picture and the
picture now has has very very
complicated I would say I would say the
picture now has human modernity taking
shape by about 70,000 years ago in other
words in other words Homo sapiens have
at least this Elle lineage were
essentially like us then if without all
kinds of attainments that have come
since then but they were essentially
like us and I'm just waiting for the
moment when musical instruments 30,000
years older than that that Griffin ulna
are found in Africa I'm convinced that
they were that they were doing given the
technologies that are that are now
recorded for them that they were doing
just in immensely complicated things 103
thousand years ago blombo's cave they
keep digging down and down and down in
this cave on the southern African coast
the deeper they get the older they get
of course in one hundred and three
thousand years ago is the level to which
they came a number of years ago a number
about 10 years ago they got to 103
thousand year level where they found
paint pots in essence abalone shells
that had paint dried paint mixtures in
with the stirring sticks there to right
103 thousand years ago they're painting
their bodies they're painting something
they're doing all kinds of stuff right
so now that's that and that sort of
extends your your trajectory a little
bit farther back the question of the
acceleration is of course then the real
the real kernel of your question and
it's a very interesting thing I think
that burgeoning epicycles explained the
acceleration that they and I've talked
about this a lot in culture in the
course of human evolution the way in
which this this the the production of
epicycles could could spur not only it
it's partly that the that the what it
Spurs is is a a quickening accumulation
of cultural archives as I as I as I tend
to call them that is to say of the
amount the sheer amount of material that
has passed along from generation to
generation that has something to do
obviously with cognitive development and
all kinds of other things as well and
this is hugely complicated to get out
but it seems to me it also has something
to do with the need in a deepening
cultural archive to systematize what is
transmitted the function of those
systems then in driving forward towards
new systems and finally accelerating the
whole process so there's a kind of yeah
I wouldn't call it bootstrapping because
that's associated with with other views
of hominid evolution that I don't quite
agree with it's a term of art that is
used for them but it is like that it is
it is as if it is as if the very process
of of the formation of these epicycles
is one that is going to that is going to
accelerate the the accumulation of more
cultural material to form more cultural
epicycles so something along those lines
is where I go with that yeah yeah okay
hello country so I'm not sure I
understood you correctly but I perceived
as if you were suggesting that
differentiation is a relatively late
events in your hierarchy and I'm
surprised about this because I think
because this episode was that you talk
about are in a way arbitrary right you
know ecologically necessary yeah and
since they are arbitrary so culture of
differentiation should actually happen
as soon as there are epicycles because
you know different episodes are likely
to arise in the population yeah so so
I've put I put the burgeoning of
cultural difference back 70 to 100
thousand years right it's not that
reason first of all right but and that's
the first thing so I'm stretching it
back a little bit farther than that so
the beat making the bead making epicycle
is a good instance of this that is to
say and it is an instance of the way in
which these couple that cultural
epicycles are not in fact arbitrary but
depend on the affordance in constraint
of a particular environment right there
is it it is again if you think of the
bead making example it's not entirely
arbitrary if there is a pressure from
growing social complexity to mark the
complexity somehow certain things are
going to are going to pop up in the
cultural in the cultural practices of of
a society and other things they're not
going to pop up those things that do pop
up have to do with the capabilities of
the humans that are doing them but they
also have to do with the affordance and
constraint of the environment right so I
don't think arbitrary I don't think
arbitrariness is the right word for the
epicycles as a whole but I do take your
I do take your point
bopper - yeah that indeed opportunity is
is is is another word I mean these are
these this is catalysed you know to use
a word from from your from your neck of
the woods and molecular biology right
this this is this is a canalized kind of
cultural development that that is part
and parcel of the of the ongoing cycle
of niche construction but your question
still remains as to shouldn't difference
be popping up as soon as these things
and I say yes it should yes it is so I
didn't mean to say that that I what I
what I meant to say about recent
cultural difference in in in homo
sapiens is
it has enabled it is part of it is part
and parcel of what has enabled the
populating in the whole world on a much
more limited scale humans in northern
Germany are making spruce javelins
because that's what they need that's
what they got there and that that's what
their technology and their cognition
will allow them to do so that is a kind
of cultural difference the bead making
the differences in bead materials is a
kind of cultural difference that comes
to be fixed and solidified in cultures
yeah I think that's true well well you
know that's it's a good question but you
know look at look at this this homo
luzon incest announced last week right
Howell lose an incest is is by the the
preliminary announcement of this I mean
they've been studying it for years these
fossils were found a while ago and they
only now release this this is a creature
about four feet tall that managed to get
to the island of luzon and and was
active they're somewhere between seventy
and fifty thousand years ago something
on that order right
it is not Homo sapiens so it's a
different lineage now a million million
and three-quarters one and
three-quarters million years ago there
were earlier waves of hominins coming
out of africa homo erectus was one big
group in africa that is usually in as
soon as Eurasian versions called Homo
ergaster right but so you know there was
some there was by the by the way a
second a second discovery about twenty
years ago which was the Homo
floresiensis the so-called Hobbit and of
an Indonesian island of Flores right
these are unexplained we don't
understand how the the Homo ergaster
lineages continued to develop we don't
understand what kind of technology they
might have had across their evolution
there's very very little hint that they
could have had seafaring technology we
don't get that we don't understand how
to go back to Homo sapiens how they
moved as quickly as they did once they
started moving it seems unlikely and
this is partly judging from climate
patterns and so on and so forth when it
would have been easy to get out of
Africa and when not and so on it seems
unlikely that that
that Homo sapiens in the final migration
Out of Africa that did populate the
whole world that were earlier ones that
didn't last into the Levant in places
like that but in the final push that
populated the whole world it seems
unlikely that began much before 70,000
years ago but they made it to Australia
five thousand years as little as five
thousand years later this is just
astonishing how does this happen
right and where is the technology for
this to happen and yeah it's one thing
after another one question after another
how do you how do you manage to carve
you know a spruce trunk at the hardest
portion of the Bay of the avoid edit
space and and and create create such a
lovely javelin out of stone tools well
clearly you can do all kinds of things
with stone tools we know that but these
are not these are not easy feats right
so it's it is all of it astonishing the
achievements of these early humans not
only sapiens but Neanderthals the
Denisovans and other lineages that was
only discovered in the 1990s from
southern Siberia we have not all of us
but we have bits of Denisovan genes in
our in our in our gene pool there was
some interbreeding between sapiens and
Denisovans there was a good deal of
interbreeding between sapiens and
Neanderthals we now know but the
movements of these things the movements
of these populations there were waves
and waves and waves of them that we
don't know about that we have only it's
the slightest glimmerings of in in the
in the technological record it's all
extraordinary it's an extraordinary
history say to me is that just
absolutely fascinating continue to be
fascinating and you know my effort then
is is to propose a model that helps us
to understand how some of this mobility
some of this differentiation of how all
of it could come about that is not
requiring some miracle gene that makes
us linguistic creatures for example but
rather has a different set of
biocultural interdependencies that is
that is what spells the the changes over
several hundred thousand years I don't
know whether that helps you very much
but
hold the mic up further hold the mic up
what is you talk about in this culture
so yeah it's a very good very good
question the first thing to say is that
I didn't restrict culture to humans
I think whole culture is widespread
through a large group of animals in the
world today however there's a difference
between social organization and
complexity in ants and social
organization and complexity say in a
group of chimpanzees and the difference
has everything to do with the learning
of information that you then transmit to
the next generation and snow do that
right they are they are genetically they
are genetically programmed to do certain
things
and interact with one another in certain
ways I think cuddle fish which are
fascinating cuttlefish have you did
mention cuttlefish didn't you yeah
cuttlefish have as many as 30 to 35
different flashing signs you know I once
saw a film an amazing film of of
somebody who in a laboratory held an
American flag up in front of in front of
thing and honest to god it flashed red
white and blue and it's just amazing
yeah so so they had these extraordinary
these extraordinary semiotic capacities
and the chromatophores and they're in
there in and those are hooked up to
neurons and all kinds of complicated
ways I never want to underplay the
complexity of cephalopods Aalto
octopuses are amazing squids are amazing
cuttlefish are amazing
yeah I don't know I don't know that we
have any evidence that that octopuses
squid and cuttlefish are cultural
animals according to the the outlines
that I've been talking about here but we
do have evidence there that they do very
very complicated things the latest
report I saw was an octopus using a
shell as a tool you know tool tool using
octopuses who'd a thunk
but it seems you know it's it's
extraordinary yeah yeah I will say one
more thing about this the in answer to
this question the one thing I never
want to do in trying to emphasize I
don't think one has to de-emphasize the
complexity of other animals inserted in
order to emphasize the complexity of
humans that's simply not a dichotomy
that is useful to me other animals do
amazing things ask Rick he knows yeah go
ahead
Francesco yes thank you so much beside
some technical question we can discuss
during the papal there are two point one
point that is important to me in this
wonderful depiction you you gave us some
of the passages imply at least two
things that are worthy of management
first there are passages that serve or
look at different and opposed opposite
goals for example the passage on from in
hyper indexicality to offline is
instrumental both to the construction of
an archive and the construction of an
imagination okay and the second is every
passage implies also losses I didn't
hear that means you lose some yeah for
example to go offline it's a dramatic
moment in which you lose contact with
the reality reality goes away and you
need to say goodbye to reality in order
to perform a number of semiotic arts and
this is a very dramatic moment in which
you're no longer tuned with the reality
and you have to refurbish or re-launched
the circle of the entire semiosis in
order to fulfill this lack yeah it's
it's tremendously dramatic Francesco I
agree but I don't necessarily agree that
you in fact have to lose reality in
order to get this expanded imaginary so
what is happening with with with a
with you know humans 40,000 years ago
painting mammoths on the cave wall there
is an exercise of the offline
imagination and it's clear that they're
not hunting the mammoths at that moment
when they're painting it right so maybe
that counts as a loss however what they
are doing is it is well I see it more
more as an expanded reality rather than
rather than a loss of touch with reality
right what they are doing is expanding
the reality so that something is brought
into the cave with a presence that it
hadn't had in the cave before all right
and that so so I I would only disagree
with the with the question with the with
the vocabulary of loss that is that at
that moment they well sure well when
they were when they were when they were
painting these animals on the walls they
hadn't killed them all off right there
were plenty of woolly mammoths out out
outside the cave when they were painting
these pictures right
we know that's that for a fact I'm not
saying yeah you don't have to agree it's
it is simply true right so so so yes but
these were these are animals that that
these humans hunted they were animals
that they interacted with in in all the
complex ways that such complex parts of
niche construction would interact with
one another to expand the horizon of
that niche construction so that they are
brought into the cave is very very
dramatic as you say yeah absolutely
dramatic and suggest well it suggests
among other things it suggests to me the
double indexicality of ritual at work
right to suggest something like that
yeah oh it's right at the heart of it
okay I mean by which you mean the
philosophers intention ality not not not
my intent to do something yeah indeed
the intentionality is in fact a question
of aboutness right it is about a mind
directed to something my notion of
semiosis is about minds that are
directed in that notion of attention as
opposed to intention but it is it seems
to me attention that is going to be a
foundation for intentionality
so intentionality then is a useful
philosophers term it's a very important
one obviously lots of philosophers talk
about it but it is one that is that is
fixed on human states of mind and my the
reason that I don't use
term is precisely to pray them should
get away from that yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it is related yeah thank you all
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]